en el último vídeo aprendimos un poco
acerca de los círculos y el círculo es
realmente un caso especial de una elipse
y decimos que es un caso especial pues
siempre tiene una distancia igual del
centro a cualquier punto de la
circunferencia mientras que en elipse en
la distancia del centro a dicho círculo
circunferencia siempre cambia y bueno en
un vídeo anterior también vimos cómo
luce una elipse pero bueno vamos a
hacerlo algo así por aquí lo que quiero
decir con esto es que el radio a partir
del centro voy a dibujar aquí un centro
que el radio a partir del centro como
ves por aquí sería el centro a este
punto sería como la distancia más corta
del origen hacia este punto y luego bien
si nos fijamos también sería por esta
parte y ahora esta distancia de acá
sería la más lejana del origen a la
circunferencia o lo que tenemos en el
borde entonces el círculo es un caso
especial de esto pues en este caso el
más lejano que obtengamos a partir del
origen es el mismo que el más cercano
desde
entonces siempre tendremos la misma
distancia para cualquier punto a partir
del origen ahora bien dicho todo esto
vamos a introducirnos un poco más en lo
matemático y la forma general o
estandarizada de una elipse centrada en
el origen sería la siguiente llegada
sobre b cuadrada igual a 1 donde a y b
son simplemente dos números cualquiera
pues también pude haber escrito be
cuadrada o sé cuadrada pues simplemente
sería una notación para ponerlos pero
para dar una idea de lo que esto
significa es haciéndonos una pregunta
acerca de nuestra elipse a estará
representando la longitud del radio en
dirección de la equis recuerda que
tenemos al cuadrado aquí entonces si
tomas la raíz cuadrada de cualquiera que
sea el denominador es el radio para las
equis entonces esta distancia es nuestro
pequeño carácter que tenemos en nuestra
gráfica entonces la distancia de a es el
punto que tenemos de aquí al origen
entonces este punto sería como a cero y
por acá tendríamos menos
pruebe entonces el radio para la
dirección en que será este radio de aquí
y quién sería ve por lo que este punto
también representaría para las equis
igual a cero y para allí ve y por acá
abajo igualmente tendríamos cero coma
menos b en cómo dibujamos aquí nuestra
elipse es un tanto más aplastada y no
tan alta en cuanto al eje de la siesta y
todo esto varía dependiendo lo que
tengamos en nuestro denominador pero
bueno la puedes obtener así o también
podría ser más corta y larga aunque la
que tenemos aquí sería llamada para esta
parte el eje menor y entonces ven no
recuerdo exactamente la terminología
pero lo podemos llamar la longitud del
semieje del semieje menor y cómo es que
decimos esto bueno pues si este es el
eje menor luego entonces le llamamos
semieje menor el semi viene
representando la mitad d
de diámetro y el mg menor porque en este
caso este es nuestro eje menor pero así
fue en nuestro ejemplo porque me fue más
pequeño que a y si ve es más largo que
entonces tendríamos una elipse muy alta
y delgada de hecho mejor la voy a
dibujar para que visualices cómo se
vería para cuando ésta digo b es mayor
entonces se vería algo así dado que en
este caso sería el semieje mayor
y ya es más pequeño por lo que resulta
ser más alta que amplia pero ya que la
visualizas te la vamos a quitar para no
confundirnos con nuestro otro ejemplo en
este caso a ser a la longitud de iu y
creo que ya lo adivina este a sería la
longitud de el semieje mayor a
representaría en nuestro ejemplo el
semieje mayor o incluso podrías no
nombrarlo como la longitud del radio
mayor que creo que hace más sentido y
también al otro lo puede llamar longitud
del radio menor
le pondríamos longitud del radio menor
ya que tenemos todo esto y que hemos
visualizado las distintas formas de la
elipse pasemos a un ejemplo un tanto
numérico que aunque antes ya habíamos
tenido ejemplos numéricos en este hay
que hacer algo más claro enfocado hacia
la elipse no entonces tenemos la
siguiente ecuación de la elipse que en
este caso sería estandarizada sentada al
origen de cuadrada sobre 25 igual a 1
así que cuál sería el radio en dirección
de las x entonces de aquí sería el radio
en dirección de las x este 9 pero está
elevado al cuadrado entonces si tu radio
en dirección de las x es cuadrada igual
a 9 entonces esa sería igual a 3 y en el
caso de be cuadrada sería b igual a 5
así que si queremos graficar esto una
vez más con el centro en el origen pero
bueno primero que todo tenemos que
nuestro radio en dirección del aire es
más grande o largo que a por lo que
nuestra elipse será alta
y va a lucir algo así dibujando los ejes
también para ubicarnos esto sería el eje
x y este de acá se aleja ya y entonces
estas distancias sería en el radio en
dirección ayer sería la distancia de
aquí que es igual a 5 esta distancia de
aquí sería igual a 5 para en cuanto a
leyes y en cuanto a las x en dirección
de las x sería esta distancia que es
igual a 3 y ya ha dicho esto y teniendo
la elipse plasmada visualicemos porque
se dice que la circunferencia o el
círculo es un caso especial o particular
de la elipse y viene el último vídeo
vimos que la ecuación para un círculo
que está centrado en su origen es x
cuadrada
y el cuadrada igual a re cuadrada así
que si dividimos ambas partes
/ r cuadrada esto sería igual y bueno
simplemente haremos un poco de
manipulación algebraica y tenemos que es
x cuadrada sobre el re cuadrada más re
cuadradas sobre ere cuadrada igual a 1 y
ahora en este caso to es igual a r y
también tuve es igual a r entonces tú
tienes el mismo la misma distancia en
cuanto al semieje menor y el semieje
mayor o en pocas palabras no hay como
más largos y más cortos sino es un
círculo perfecto y es por eso que el
círculo es un caso particular de dicha
elipse pero bueno hagamos un ligero
avance y ahí compliquemos un tanto las
cosas como quizás podría venir tiene un
examen con un pequeño cambio entonces
digamos que queremos cambiar esta elipse
a esta ecuación y digamos que queremos
cambiarla
a la derecha por 5 o sea que queremos
recorrer las 5 unidades en lugar de que
comience en el origen va a estar
recorrido hacia x igual a 5 y pensando
en esto sería que como cuáles serían los
términos que hay que cambiar o modificar
para que pase dicho punto y bueno este
término de aquí es para cuando estamos
en el origen es cero cuando x vale cero
entonces ahora estamos recorridos cinco
unidades entonces no va a ser x así sin
nada entonces vamos a reescribir lo acá
abajo y después lo dibujamos para no
confundirnos sería x menos 5 sobre 9
dado que así aquí x es igual a 5 esto se
vuelve 0 entonces es equivalente a lo
que teníamos arriba lo que tenemos por
acá para cuando x vale a 0 y bueno
nuestra elipse se ve algo así y eso es
algo que aprendimos cuando teníamos la
ecuación del círculo entonces al haberle
restado a x algo significa que nuestro
nuevo origen estará en
algo o sea estar en este caso en más 5 y
podrás memorizar esto que cuando tengas
x menos un número este número es
positivo en cuanto al origen y lo
contrario para el otro caso pero la
forma correcta de pensar esto es que si
vamos para x igual a 5 este término de
aquí este término de x menos 5 se
comporta más o menos igual para cuando
estábamos sentados en el origen pues
cuando x vale 5 este término se hace 0
aquí x igual a 0 el término se hacía
cero que es para marcar el origen y
luego si ahora nos fijamos lo que
tenemos de ye cuadrada sobre 25 igual a
1 para darle los valores a ayer vamos a
ver que toma valores de más 5 y menos 5
para ese lado del diámetro para calcular
los radios aunque lo realmente
importante aquí es que lo hagas con
mucha intuición y luego digamos que
queremos volver a cambiar la ecuación
pero ahora recorriendo la elipse dos
unidades hacia abajo entonces queremos
bajarla
dos unidades y bueno todo esto lo que
hemos estado aprendiendo en las
secciones de cónicas es verdad es
realmente importante para cualquier
función entonces para cambiarla de esta
forma y mover la gráfica hacia la
derecha cinco unidades lo reemplaza en
el eje de la x y xi ahora lo queremos
recorrer hacia abajo dos unidades hay
que modificar para layer entonces hay
que reemplazar para la yes de la
siguiente forma como estamos haciéndolo
menos dos unidades hacia abajo entonces
a la hora de modificar la ecuación sería
con el término positivo como lo habíamos
comentado anteriormente y nuestra elipse
se va a ver algo así por lo que ahora sí
sí nos vamos a nuestra ecuación por acá
abajo
para x ya habíamos visto que era x menos
5 por las 5 unidades hacia la derecha al
cuadrado sobre 9 más ahora tendríamos
aquí y más 2 al cuadrado sobre 25 igual
a 1 siempre es como con el signo
contrario y una vez más la razón de lo
que esto pasa aquí es porque cuando es
igual a menos 2 este término se hace
cero entonces estamos hablando del mismo
punto en la curva bueno más bien no del
mismo punto en la curva estamos hablando
del mismo caso para cuando nuestro
término se convierte o se hace cero por
lo que no estamos hablando exactamente
del mismo punto pues está viendo la
elipse de forma diferente pero hablamos
como de lo mismo en cuanto a lo que se
convierte el término puesto que lo voy a
mencionar una vez más para cuando llegue
es igual a menos 2 el término se hace
cero y para el caso de con está centrada
en el origen sí que vale cero ese
término completo se hace cero a lo que
me refiero es como si tuviéramos un
punto
máximo una especie de punto que está
siendo evidente en cómo está marcando
nuestra ecuación pero bueno yo no quiero
hacerlo más confuso y ahora jugando con
todo lo que ya sabemos hay que ver cómo
sería la gráfica de la siguiente
ecuación entonces tenemos ya menos 1 al
cuadrado sobre 4 más x más 2 al cuadrado
sobre el 9 igual a 1 y la primera cosa
que podríamos decir aquí es ok
bueno pues buscando la forma estándar
que ya conocemos de las elipses
cuadradas sobre 4 más x cuadradas sobre
9 igual a 1 es algo como esto pero está
solamente como recorrido un poco puesto
que lo de aquí abajo tiene un origen en
0,0 mientras que la parte de acá arriba
tendría un origen en menos dos más uno y
ahora sí gráfica nos esto el radio en la
dirección de la aie es 2 pues 2 al
cuadrado nos va a dar 4 recordemos que
los términos estarían como llevados al
cuadrado y luego tendríamos que sería 3
pues al cuadrado es 9 así que
con esto para la dirección de las equis
es más larga que para las llaves
entonces será una elipse un tanto gorda
pero primero dibujemos los ejes entonces
aquí tenemos nuestro eje vertical
nuestro eje de las íes y luego por acá
vamos a tener nuestro eje de las equis
es nuestro eje de las equis y buscamos
el punto menos 2,1 que es el origen de
la elipse para que tenemos menos uno
menos dos y una unidad hacia arriba por
aquí tenemos el origen y ahora este es
nuestro centro de la elipse y teniendo
nuestro radio para la dirección de las
equis sería nuestro radio es tres
entonces tres unidades a la derecha y
tres unidades a la izquierda
y en otra dirección para cuando llegue
nuestro radio estos así que subimos dos
unidades y también bajamos dos unidades
así que trataré de hacer mi mejor
captura para nuestra elipse y sería algo
de esta forma es un poco más gordita que
alargada y esto es porque nuestro radio
de las x es más largo que el rey de
leyes y luego estas distancias de por
aquí es 3 y de por acá también es 3 por
acá tenemos 2 y hacia abajo también 2 y
este es el punto ahora en el que puedes
fijarte lo que cada parte hace y no lo
voy a estar enfocando todo porque ya
tardamos bastante tiempo pero sería un
buen trabajo que tú te fijarás lo que es
cada punto por acá vamos a tener el
punto 1 1 1 por acá tendríamos el punto
al tenerle que quitar dos unidades menos
5,1 y puedes visualizar también nosotros
para tu ejercitar y en futuros vídeos
probablemente sea más fácil simplificar
esta forma pues tú ya sabes que es una
elipse